-We're about to play
a game called
the "Best Friends Challenge."
But to do that, we're gonna need
a couple of best friends.
First up, he's this season's
Mega Mentor
on "The Voice" on NBC,
and he co-founded
the new boxing league
Triller Fight Club.
Please welcome Snoop Dogg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Awesome, man! Yes!
That's my man. Come on, bud.
And she's the lead judge
on the new Discovery Plus show
"Clipped."
Please welcome Martha Stewart!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, no, come on now!
No!
Mwah! I catch it!
Mwah! I'll take it!
I love you guys.
Now, Snoop and Martha,
you two have been best friends
for years --
or have been friends for years,
but we've wondered --
do you ever wonder if you guys
might be best friends?
There you go.
-Snoop?
Hey, Snoop.
-Martha is my best "FF."
I can't say that
'cause we on NBC, but my BFF.
-Okay.
-Best friend forever.
-Nah.
-I gotcha. Alright.
We have a game --
[ Laughter ]
I gotcha, dude.
We have a game we can play
to prove that you guys
are best friends.
It's time for
the "Best Friends Challenge."
Here we go.
-♪ Best friends challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Now, the game works
like this --
it's like "The Newlywed Game,"
but for friends.
I'm gonna read you questions
about each other
from the best friends box
and you'll try to write down
the same answer.
Make sense?
Okay, good.
-Great.
-Here is the first question
right here.
It says, "What is Snoop's
favorite thing to cook?"
So, Snoop, you write down
the real answer.
Martha, you write down
what you think
Snoop's answer is going to be.
What is Snoop's favorite thing
to cook?
[ Chuckling ]
-Okay.
-Alright, wow.
You seem confident.
Okay.
Martha, what did you write?
Fried chicken with corn flakes.
Sounds good.
-[ Laughing ]
Snoop?
-Oh, no!
-Chicken wings.
Ah, we'll take that!
[ Ding ]
-Okay.
-Right? That's a match!
That's a match!
Wait, I like that you put
corn flakes on them.
-[ Laughs ] I put Frosted Flakes
on it, baby.
-He always adds something
sort of regular,
common, you know,
to his food, and it makes it
taste so good.
-[ Laughs ] I love that one.
Okay, here we go.
It's our next question.
Alright.
"If Martha was
an alcoholic beverage,
what would she be?"
Snoop, Martha,
you write that down.
There you go.
Whenever you're ready.
Take your time.
-I'm writing it down.
-Take your time.
♪♪
Okay. Here we go.
Snoop, what did you write?
Vodka.
Really?
-Uh-oh.
-I think Martha's
a whiskey girl, myself.
Martha-rita!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, wow. Oh, wow.
-You forgot, Snoop, you forgot.
-A Martha-rita.
Come on, that's it.
-You forgot.
-Blame it on the medicine I had
before the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Hee-hee! Ah, okay.
Next question is,
"If Snoop had to choose
a different profession,
what would he do?"
Snoop, you write
the real answer.
Martha, write what you think.
If Snoop had to choose
a different profession,
what would he do?
♪♪
-Okay.
-Alright.
Martha, what did you write?
A basketball star or a coach.
[ Gasps ] Snoop?
A pastor!
[ Laughter ]
Come on now.
Absolutely.
Come on, absolutely.
Oh, come on, absolutely!
Oh, no, no! Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God.
-Really, Snoop? Really?
Really, really?
I noticed he was changing,
Jimmy.
-Yeah, you knew? Yeah.
-I noticed, but...
I didn't know
he was going that far.
-Yeah, well,
you know what they say --
glory to God in the highest.
-Yes, brother.
[ Laughter ]
Mighty clouds of joy.
-Let's do one more.
Here we go. Ready?
-We're doing badly, Snoop.
-Complete this sentence --
"Martha has the world's
greatest blank."
[ Laughter ]
Martha has the world's
greatest blank.
♪♪
-Oh, boy.
-[ Laughing ] Martha!
You can -- [ Laughing ]
-I can write forever.
-This is good.
I could play this game forever.
I love this.
Alright, here we go. It's time.
Snoop, what did you write?
Martha has
the world's greatest...
Outlook on cooking.
-Wow!
-Look at that!
[ Applause ]
Getting real.
Martha, what is yours?
Martha has
the world's greatest...
"Grandchildren --
other than Snoop."
See, come on.
This is what I'm talking about.
[ Audience awws ]
That's...
That's two good people
right there.
Martha Stewart and Snoop Dogg,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to see you guys.
Check out their new line
of Bic EZ Reach Lighters
coming out this summer.
We're talking to Snoop more
after the break.
Stick around!